biotonix on the outskirts of the district for the
benefit of the
premium about a dispute tv gives in 1912
a welcome to the images one by the pact
can't be tamed minkébé relax early for
example excellent text does not authorize
[Music]
maggiore investigate tube est  in the
firmament foolishness a dozen doe all
plain plain natural gas yes up and
shock me no bastille atmosphere
since it should be in knicks
angie nacho gas in various in french
tuniso equal to 2 nancy and fiuggi mix
hello sir 28 cm shortly  I
represent the African press
you like the African press louis
and part of the African press
finally different media of the post alone
from Africa in particular the fight and the
point you presented as a
great ambition of Europe
this green pact but  we can imagine that
the ambitions of europe can also
lead to the interests and
concerns of africa depending on the
weather, more than we have been following you very closely
since you took office  tion
then can we imagine that this
green pact is included in
the cooperation agenda of the new
cooperation that seems to be taking shape
between europe and africa because
climate issues are of paramount
importance?
talks very little about it Africa is
not just about migration issues
there are the climatic effects which have a
great impact on the most disadvantaged populations
the erosion of coastal zones leads
to displacements both in
the interior and at the level of
the  outside and there is a new
ecological awareness that has been taking
place for some time in africa
so here
you are talking about impact studies
does this impact study also take into
account the interests of your
african partners since you  have the ambition
to reach out to them in the framework of
two new partnerships
here I can give you a
very very precise and concrete answer the
prison of selling hatred has already  been in
africa she has already spoken with the
president of the african afic and she
came back with the conclusion that for
the next meeting of the
european commission with the commission of the african union
we will have a debate on the green deal so
it  is already concluded there is a great interest
on the African side to be part of these
discussions is to see if we can
make projects together
me personally I believe that your
energy field there is really an
incredible opportunity for
cooperation between the  Europe and Africa
we are already seeing in some
African countries that people citizens who
have not yet had access to any
form of energy at all are getting
direct access to electricity which has been
created by photovoltaics
immediately  so we're really taking a
leap forward and that's what I believe
more fundamentally is an
incredible opportunity for africa not to have to
go through all this development of
the third revolution  industrial solution
and two to go immediately to the
fourth with all the opportunities
we have, especially given the
demographic composition of
African countries with all this very,
very talented and increasingly better
educated youth who will give us the possibility
that the possibilities of creating
enormous economic opportunities is
also a possibility of creating a link
between the two continents because well
if Africa and Europe do
not take each other into account who will do it the
others will not it will depend on  we
[Music]
for at least three years and attractive
at the bottom of this chinese section state who
needs and investment bank
rando gives 6 tibet turn merry-go-round where
we are and rape facing him alone
he contrasts piccoli and catherine
mixed company on the web in quebec  to
save water like being told you
came in through the bathroom animals ex
john doe's ex job i.e. what
have so brand fashion weeks and our
countries do dat  e these dates also
transported again j we want to make
you drop in cave de mauritania agent
dasté mobility of mobility france is a
copé the text hadopi only had a
label of witness and nash our
platforms tic tac this price  hated 12:30 p.m.
king's day in the grave on
burgundy pinot china france in quarters
kof syntax was categorical to the
manager for managing this day here
annie roux for context I would like to
extend a little bit the questions on
the taxation of the  energy and transport
you want to revise the directive on the
tax or taxation of energy sorry
and for that you want to pass with a
qualified majority and no
longer unanimity
can you tell us when
are you going to go about it because  that this is
precisely what led in particular to the
cancellation of the previous revision and
second question you spoke of
trains in your communication you
say that you really want to
develop the modal shift towards the
rail and river transport this
is something that has been in the doctrine
of the commission for many
years so what is
this time you are going to do to make
it really a reality
thank you on the first question  yes the
commission intends to use the
gateway clause because like
that the directive really needs to be changed we
can't leave it like that the
conditions outside have
fundamentally changed we have to change the
legislation
you're right it will depend  of the
will of the member states to accept a
bridge because to accept the
bridge you need a decision within it
a limit but I believe that the sense
of urgency among the member states to
increase
this has nevertheless changed so we are going in
any case  try to make a
proposal that could be
interesting for the member states but
we can no longer leave the subject aside
we really have to tackle it on the
trains when we see today  today what
are the constraints that block the choice
for transport to use the train
it is above all the time it takes a
train we have a europe without borders
but if we take the train and the
borders everywhere and the trains satan
very  a long time at the borders because
there are different rules between
the member states on electricity
safety sometimes you have to change the railway workers
etc etc
and so there I think we really have to
make an advance and there too you are
asking me  of just this title is
what has changed what has changed
is it's
sense of urgency that has been proven
by citizens everywhere and if we really want to
give the possibility of having
to the citizen  to move around without having
too much of an impact on our environment,
we have to give them possibilities
such as using trains, but
above all for the transport we
need,
it's too much on trucks, we
really have to use the potential of
t  rains and I know examples
where it works very well you still have to
study for example the Swiss example
they have enormously increased the
percentage of transport on the being and
I am very interested in seeing why
how what are the measures that
they took and so it's really I
it's an important issue for the European economy
and when we ask companies
why you don't use the train
because we don't know exactly when
our product will arrive because  we
hit this model just in time and it does
n't work it's not sure when the
product arrives at its destination
and here we go I think what we
could do
and it's urgent it's urgent because
simply to continue as we  the fact
now that will not bring us to
carbon neutrality in 2050
this weekend the national climate energy
complain as soon as possible the com of
specific vlaamse of this fact of the cycle
churches or moody's a mark is that
we will quickly all s  e rule by a
fan of its activities it
might have that this group missed
yes hello pascal zentz people are
a small question of clarification the
just transition mechanism will therefore be
for all regions while the
just transition fund will be 37  rather
targeted on the strange the
coal regions if I understand correctly
yeah okay
is that no no not only
coal regions sorry I was already two
steps forward
the mechanism can apply to all no
the fund will be for regions  where there are
particular transition specificities it can be coal regions
it can be regions with
an industry in difficulty
very specific social issues
of employment etc
it is not only coal but
but  really for regions in
difficulty
sorry sorry
in this context is what for the
european commission this
just transition fund is a solution for
perhaps  e facilitated negotiations on the
nego box since that way we
could perhaps maintain reductions on
the envelope of the cohesion policy
while perhaps allocating more
financial resources to the coal regions or
in need which are
mainly perhaps  -being in the countries
of central and eastern Europe
well I would say more generally not
only on coal to have an
agreement on the multi-annual budget
we will have to convince this country which does
not say one euro more and the countries which
do not say this  number increases who has a
compromise a few steps and found this
compromise and I believe that
redirecting part of
European finances towards the green deal could
help those who have problems
accepting a slightly higher budget
to also tell the constituents
in the country
listen  maybe we pay a little more
but now we really have a
reorientation towards new
policies because what I fear and
c  it's all gamer it's I think the
fourth time I've experienced them what
I'm afraid you know that the compromise
would be to leave everything as it is to
find compromises by lowering the
funds which are aimed at a new
economy  which aims at the climate and leaving
everything as it is in the
agricultural policy in the structural policy
and that's it, that would be a
really very disappointing result and that would
deprive us of the possibilities of really
investing in the new economy and of
investing in measures  to
achieve climate neutrality by 2050
so here I really see the need
to create a dynamism between these two
groups of countries by saying well it
is perhaps a little more than you would have
liked but at the same time we are redirecting
our workforce  forward rather than
backward
that country aboard taxes at crosby jean
and yes man dies hostile forces like that
[Music]